you think whatever kill pops is out
there
[Music]
so what happens next
hello everyone i'm jacqueline coley a
correspondent with fandango and it is my
honor to welcome you to the first
interview with the cast and filmmakers
of nope folks i am so excited for this
but jordan i have to start with you
because we don't know that much about
this phone but what we do know is that
you shot it on 65 millimeter and imax
and there are special effects i mean
what was it about this story that said
to yourself we've got to go bigger
well you know i wrote it in a time when
we were a little bit worried about the
future of cinema so the first thing i
knew is i i wanted to create a spectacle
i wanted to create something that the
audience would have to come see
and so you know i set my my sights on um
you know the great american ufo story
here
and the movie itself uh deals with
spectacle and and the good and bad that
come from this idea of attention and the
title it's right there because like from
the minute i got it i was like this just
must be the energy of that interview
reporter when the buffalo were coming to
him and he's just like nope not today
i'm like am i guessing is that is that
all right oh definitely okay
it's a horror epic but it has some
points in it that are meant to elicit a
very audible reaction in the theater um
so hopefully when we go see it we're
going to hear a lot of no
all right
walking back in
that's what i'm looking for i feel like
i will uh daniel it's so crazy because
like i just feel blessed to be here
because it feels like such a homecoming
the fact that you guys are doing another
film together after get out like that
was such a gift to all of us but talk
about your relationship i remember you
talking about even through the judas you
guys have kept in touch your friendship
was so built through the get out
experience what was it like coming back
to set
and everything both of you have done
since then i was like really proud of
jordan
saying it's like that that's the reality
like it's um
to be on someone's first film at such a
vulnerable moment saying it's like and
if we didn't we lost the location before
like we changed states i mean it was
like tough and then you just see him
like oh wow look what he's it made able
to not a lot of directors get to grow
like that you know i mean it's like it's
the reality so
the fact that he he's work it get out
worked and then us worked and then he's
got to this level and and he's able to
to to have me a part of a part of this
on on this level of budget it's like i
just felt really proud of jordan and and
yeah man that was get back to back in
our bag you know talking about character
and the story on set you mean to me and
making up so i was kind of hoping that i
could like
act like i was the reason he's
you know what i mean but then he came
with his fresh oscar and you know i had
nothing to do with it so the power
dynamic has shifted
but like can we talk about the pedigree
here though we got two oscar winners we
got an oscar nominee and i'm i'm feeling
based on your interviews girl just with
vanity fair that should have won an
oscar so like let's talk about it
i mean i don't know this man i would
have given that an oscar but i will say
we don't know anything about this movie
or at least at this point of filming we
didn't but you did say something in an
interview that i was like zeroed in on
and you said that it shocked you like
what you were able to sort of do with
this character so first of all what's
the t what's shocking and then also you
get i know just watching how booked and
busy you are you get offers what was it
about this one that made you say i have
to play this game girl i ain't getting
offers like jordan peele
girl hey all i heard was jordan p would
like to talk to you about his next film
and i
say that was like immediate i'm a huge
fan of jordan peel i mean he also is a
big part of like when people see me do
my comedy now he gave me my first
opportunity with sketch on key and peel
yeah i mean he's he's always seen it for
me i guess you could say so to get the
opportunity to
grow with him from key appeal to being
in one of his films
it was like an opportunity that i was
just very grateful to get
and then i was shocked because of
all of the different archetypes that he
was able to put in each character he
that's really like it was really
original the way that he designed each
character and specifically obviously you
know i'm looking at my character because
i have to perform it and there were a
lot of different places that i had to go
and i think within my career you do see
me do a lot of different things kiki
palmer the host kiki the actor kiki the
comedian character and he found a way to
access
all the things that make me me um in one
in one role which is just like that's
really skilled writing
i love that so much i also really love
that you're in this and so you're just
going to be doing movies so you won't be
taken as a working host any more jobs
that we would have to have because like
sis is too much of a multi-hyphenate
we're never going to have a job
it's a real talk so i'm like girl let's
let's do all your movie things i'm just
kidding now uh stephen i i was i was
thinking about it getting ready for this
interview like you're so it's crazy to
say a veteran of genre like a mayhem
burning which is like a thriller and a
slow thrower and then obviously even
like sorry to bother you with that
absurdist comedy and coming to do this
as a veteran of it and even like with
the twilight zone stuff i know you've
seen probably the tropes you know
through
all of these various iterations of
scripts what is it about this film that
really sets it apart that really pushes
it great question i think
i think um through that experience the
thing that i have learned is
in those genre setups uh it's easy to
maybe rely on the tropes but really i
think we're all looking for something
deeply human
um
and that's what makes it unsettling and
i think
you know when i was uh when jordan asked
me to be a part of this
uh we had a lot of conversations
um and i think we could have left it at
certain
places or tables where it would have
ended up maybe being more of a trope or
it could have become a construct but we
never really let the conversation
live there it always ended at like
a deeply human person
so for me like you know i just follow
people who see that i think jordan sees
that i don't think he's necessarily
always trying to construct something
that's like not real i think he's always
trying to talk about something that's
very real i mean it's it's very present
in just the first two films but also
when i just look at the cast that you've
assembled jordan like there's a certain
level of i would say you know your stuff
is good to like make the reach outs that
you do as far as your cast because i'm
just looking at the names you've
assembled with some of these a lot of
these folks do incredible work but
i guess how do you make that balance to
what steven said about sort of talking
through the character development
through that process on set because i
know that that's what makes these things
so i guess tangible and real a big part
of this process is
is finding
finding out what
uh each actor and i share
um and how we talk about and how we
think about the character and finding
this common ground i mean you're right
my if i have if i have
any skill as a director my greatest
skill is is casting and and a big part
of that is identifying
who i'm interested in um and
even before i talk to them
already i'm already infusing the
character with their energy so it gets
to a point where it's like i hope i get
them
because now you're kind of upset
but uh yeah i mean i was i was i'm in a
i'm in a great place right now very
fortunate i could i could shoot the moon
and get exactly who i wanted for this
film i love that so much and then you
also bring you know familiar faces back
to us or maybe less familiar faces
they're going to get a moment to be
introduced and i'm so excited for you
brandon because
like let's be real i'm just happy to do
this interview i can't imagine being on
set you know what i mean
i'm still trying to wake up
you know what was hella funny is you
were like
emmy winner oscar winner oscar winner
oscar nominee and then i'm just
who am i
let me ask you this though about it
though because i think like you know on
top of the fact that you're joining a
jordan peel project and the names that
you just said but you're also taking
like a subject that i feel like movies
will never get tired of but they'll
always find a way to do different and
that's sci-fi and horror and like
especially aliens and just the idea of
whatever it is like hovering over my
shoulder in this shot like if that was
coming down yes nope absolutely
so you can maybe just sort of articulate
like what do the sci-fi sort of like
alien fans have to look forward to in
this film
just something different
something totally new i think jordan's
changed cinema already he's going to do
it again
they gave him an opportunity to
do something on a massive scale at
the he's operating at the highest level
so it's insane that you're giving this
our tour director
this type of platform to really speak
and tell story and to do it from his
style with this type of spectacle
it's going to blow people's minds so
it's crazy to be a part of it like i
remember reading the script because when
i was reading the script i was like dang
people are gonna be flipped upside down
because they are not gonna expect this
from jordan because i remember i was
reading it expecting something else and
then i was like oh
this is like way different than what
he's ever done i was like then i was
like good
good
surprise us
so i was surprised to read it and then
now to be doing it
crazy i know this is gonna be the one
the internet's talking about so i'm just
gonna go ahead and say that right there
that is a bold statement i cannot wait
to see this um jordan i have to bring it
to you because look they teach classes
on what you were able to create let's
get out literally teach classes about
what you've done to cinema
and
i really want to just ask honestly all
the actors actually what impact you feel
that jordan's work has done to just
cinnamon general because we've all
referenced it but i do feel especially
with the more established folks like you
kiki you can definitely do a like
bj like oh sorry before jordan after
jordan
no no no no no we're not
gonna do
there is a line of demarcation before
you feel it after sure and what do you
feel that impact is besides that awful
pun of a joke
um what do i feel the impact is just
like in in terms of just like entirety
or for me personally you personally yeah
that would be great oh for me personally
jordan makes uh being a genius seem very
attainable you know what i mean
i'm directing it you know what i mean
like he makes it all seem
good really possible um
so after working with him i think i was
just really inspired the same way that i
was after i saw get out as an actor as a
creator i was just like man
you know
it's just the way that he approaches
film is not
it's not the average way it's it's as if
it's it's almost like he's a fine art
artist
and that's how he crafts his films like
he's getting ready to put on an art
museum and you know you're gonna watch
this piece and figure out what you can
take from it and they're all different
you know when it came to get out it was
like okay he was saying something that
maybe we all thought we got immediately
and then with us we realized okay wait a
minute we gotta pull continue to pull
back layers like the gag this time has
nothing to do with them being black he
just happens to be normalizing black
people being into leads but that's not
what this is about this is about
something bigger and then when it comes
to nope it's going to also then be about
something bigger but then the crazy
thing about it all is when you look at
get out us nope all of that
means something bigger and so he just
continues to just not leave it at the
door and then like cal stevens said
there's still a commercial aspect but
that's just because he knows how to get
you in the door that's him using his
emerald and then he finishes with his oj
yeah that makes sense
for the movie yeah i'm still interested
to know what song from the 90s in my
early childhood he's going to make
terrifying for me this time around and
i'm going to hold out on the trailer
department of universal for that one
daniel i'm going to ask you yours a
little bit different because you more
than anyone probably next to jordan have
felt the impact of get out
talk about like how like a tangible
moment where you're like this is even
further than i even thought two years
ago when we talked about this movie
because now that there's even more
distance it's almost like it's gotten
bigger yeah no it keeps on getting
bigger over time get out i feel like
it's um it's quite like i've never
really experienced anything like that
and then um and also you're kind of
watching it's like i'll be watching my
tv shows i watching a random tv show and
then there's like a get out reference
just in terms of how they shot the scene
and there's like you know you're like oh
wow like you just impart you just
but it's stuff that i would just watch
if i was working at a bank i'd watch
this show i mean it's like it's one of
those kind of shows so it's it's really
changed
i think what get out and jordan did is
like change what's possible
and then go and actually moved it
forward and you realize how little how
few films get to do that didn't actually
move cinema forward and that's what i
think we was blessed enough to do on
that one yeah and now we're on the train
sorry that is your impact we just keep
going so everyone tickets are on sale
for nope now and you can see it in
theaters only july 22nd
you